siendo una adolescente ya se paseaba por
las pasarelas de las semanas de la moda
del continente africano se convirtió en
una modelo una musa una inspiración
entonces como conciencia de lo que está
en juego en el ámbito social y económico
de la moda y decidió viajar por el mundo
para llevar la antorcha de la creación
africana contemporánea en un hotel
privado muy elegante del distrito 8 de
parís balear y que organiza hoy la
primera edición de elementos ser aplicas
hay una moda africana que no es una moda
étnica ni una moda que sólo se hace con
telas de cera y bubu es eso pero en
realidad la creación las colecciones de
los diseñadores si no te dicen que son
aplicadas no los aburridos es mucho
verde está muy de moda hay muchos
colores bonitos te sientes muy bien se
puede lucir en cualquier momento en
cualquier lugar lo que pasa es que hay
que descubrirlos por eso tenemos que
proponer los para que también podamos
descubrir esta creatividad africana de
una manera diferente haciendo este tipo
de eventos que es como con qué
dificultades se encuentran al preparar
un evento de esa magnitud
tenemos que organizar la llegada de los
diseñadores tenemos que encontrar socios
quería socios que pudieran formar estos
jóvenes diseñadores que nos puedan
acompañar personas que puedan luego
ayudarles formarles y arnés para que
descubran la creatividad de esta
juventud africana porque no tal vez
podría conducir a algo por encima de
todo se trata de ayudarlos el evento
está patrocinado por balenciaga lvm
galerías lafayette y la escuela de
negocios hs socios que elegirán al
ganador entre la decena de diseñadores
invitados el ganador obtendrá entre
otras cosas un año de tutoría el
problema que tenemos los africanos o uno
de los problemas que tenemos
es encontrar primero las materias primas
es decir compramos nuestros propios
materiales pero luego si queremos
intentar complementarlo con otras cosas
es un poco complicado
y luego está el problema de la venta la
búsqueda de conexiones las tiendas
fugaces todo esto es un poco difícil
para nosotros los jóvenes africanos
[Música]
otra candidata a nia libor qatar ya
nacida en dar es salaam tanzania se
trasladó a ciudad del cabo sudáfrica
para estudiar moda antes de crear su
marca en su ciudad natal donde lucha por
superar las dificultades de la vida
cotidiana
en tanzania tenemos problemas para
conseguir telas
así que las hago yo misma o las encargo
al extranjero
puede mostrarnos modelos
este conjunto está tenido a mano en
áfrica mi fuente de inspiración es la
tierra
cualquiera que sea la textura del suelo
la naturaleza las hojas cosas así
estas huellas es la tierra
otro más
esto es un poncho enorme
se combina que hay unos pantalones
oversize que una vez más se inspiran en
la textura del suelo
es una colección también para hombres no
las mujeres también pueden llevarlos
natasha lyonne y karina blow vinieron de
johannesburgo sudáfrica ellas también se
enfrentan al mismo tipo de problema uno
de los retos a los que nos enfrentamos a
menudo es el de abastecernos de muchos
tejidos naturales en ciudades así que
para esta colección utilizamos
principalmente muerte porque es fácil de
encontrar en sudáfrica para otros
materiales es complicada y hay que
importar grandes cantidades
el invitado de honor del acto imán aquí
sí nacido en camerún fue el primer
diseñador del continente africano en ser
avalado por la poderosa federación de
alta costura y moda de parís cree que
los jóvenes diseñadores tienen
dificultades para triunfar porque
carecen de elementos fundamentales
ya cuando uno viene de áfrica no se
viste en deuda cap como la base en parís
así que cuando un diseñador sale de
camerún senegal debe tener los códigos
internacionales es decir los códigos
parisinos italianos americanos o
londinenses como decir hay que hacer un
estudio de la situación en cada país
antes de ir a proponer sus productos
esto es muy importante
qué más de falta a los diseñadores
americanos hay que comprarlos hay que
comprarlos la comunicación es muy
importante la compra y la comunicación y
luego la formación también y tener la
información adecuada para poder salir al
mundo y mezclarse con los demás porque
el mundo actual es como una pequeña
aldea todo ese causado y geográfica que
forma parte de ello no se puede
prescindir de afp
y el ganador es emmanuel o coro vive y
trabaja en lagos nigeria
[Aplausos]
el estilo de nuestra colección es muy
andrógino en todo lo que hacemos
aplicamos los principios de la moda
sostenible trabajamos con un equipo de
hábiles artesanos en una remota aldea de
nigeria que fabrican los tejidos de
nuestra colección el tejido que
utilizamos es la cuenta que procede del
este de nigeria nuestra misión es
promover la artesanía porque el futuro
de la moda africana se basa en las
prácticas tradicionales el tejido el
tinte así que solo queremos promover la
moda africana y llevarla al escenario
mundial
usted optimista
realmente creo en el futuro
el acuerdo es una mezcla de rafia y
algodón balenciaga le entrenar ahora
durante seis meses hs se encargará de su
plan de negocio el futuro puede ser
brillante
[Aplausos]